hello welcome to sleeping German severn
and we'll see what happens playing the
Wii Lopez exchange the episode before
that's one of the better lines yeah him
the only challenge in movies G for which
is not something that I love to play in
a blitz cam I have to admit but what can
you do really the only thing that tests
like so I have to do it this position is
a a bit easier to play for black in
blitz he's a pawn down but his get is
getting this interesting player on the
dark squares hmm I'm a bit surprised
that he allows screen g3 year or Bishop
f4 okay coin age 7 doesn't look like a
movie he would like to play I think it
seemed
so what is he trying to do here knight
c6 and so on probably so shop here once
the dryer I need to do the same problem
he wants to play Bishop to b6 later and
then g5 so I should be ready to play
Knights e 40 m and yeah it seems fairly
reasonable so we should do sex yeah yeah
so let's do this I mean it's not the end
of the world becomes 36 I can reduce
some of his active potential and not be
three years F initely a month now I am
c5 is hanging shouldn't be forgotten the
blackest instead of porn down and you
cannot really talk about compensation he
has no compensation for the porn 95 or
taking you're taking 92 was probably
also quite good yeah take a 92 should be
should be good
c4 is hanging and turn g5g five is that
when you walk probably yeah let's stop
tricking g5 mmm ok so we age he plays it
a 1 over later I don't know if this
check helps me
hmm clock probably does the king is not
great on see aid and they have
potentially a check like on fi for
example I don't have earned I don't have
a direct tactic here at least I don't
see it
and we take sig figs I've got everything
protected this might threaten root Kade
maybe black can take twice on f4 tape on
d to take on e4 it's so quite irritating
mmm I wonder if I could have done could
have played this better somehow giving
him less chances of giving less activity
I mean here this is may be interesting
just for Queenie to Queen 86 made
Queenie to Queenie to what what's
happening King c8 and let's do this keep
it simple
Luke only one is still in a pretty safe
square so some are still tricky
move like 95 something like that it just
continues the game okay I don't know
what he's doing now I mean what foot am
I playing next Queen cop okay so we have
a clock and then is going 95 so 195 is
the black idea definitely how thats it's
also dangerous Queen up here Queenie
five that actually blunder stuff Knight
e5 Queenie to mention should do it
threatening on a6 myself so it's um it's
difficult for him to continue the attack
Quincy six maybe something like that
yeah still not not easy time morning
yeah Larry Christensen salt saying yeah
you never resign unless you have an if
you're still have a night yeah of course
my black will never resign this position
this would be completely yet I'm just
saying it's in Main Street Ricky
maybe it just takes it and then the net
can trade queens ya know it takes i can
trade queens okay
right as seven sets or something check
check I have a couple of chicks though
it should be good check he and Here Come
still don't see and win unfortunately
clustered on slowing down chick and then
check on the age Clark me took me like
years Chapman to see that oh my god I
was I don't like this line in the Blitz
game for white because here you always
feel I mean at least for me it always
feels like there is some kind of some
kind of potential for black to em to ya
to arrest your king however I think it's
he should definitely play some g5 I mean
the way it went I feel I was just a lot
better this seems weird to me that he
allowed this cane computer wants to play
g5 and then Bishop f4
that's a very good move 45 after F for
what I did black can play g5 that's
really true now there he can just give
another pawn I mean if I do this this is
getting very dangerous and if I do this
I'm completely stopping g5 that's a very
good movie I'm really good this is also
nicely showing after g5 there will
always be something on g5 my porn on my
my bishop if he takes and as long as
this is the case this is a dead piece
only seven it can never go here here and
he has to spend time we see 5 and so on
and in the meantime I play Bishop f4 so
that was a huge improvement but okay it
didn't go g5 he still can do again so
the way it went it was excellent for
white probably winning somehow of it
okay Queenie of three was stronger 45
here I was never sure if I really
threatening clock this yeah okay I went
for the simple the simple approach but
after I mean heat heat jettison that
porn I was expecting g5 immediately and
this isn't so clear I mean I cannot take
this as if i was hanging and it's not
clear or I'm in the sustained yours line
yeah I have given up a lot of good valve
advantage beforehand and here think
tanks get to get very difficult so five
yeah this was a move I kind of suspected
that this might work but I couldn't
really figure it out I give this and
there are the Queen takes ah I only saw
this and I couldn't see something
something good but I had this feeling
that it could be
idea but this is good okay as the queen
is is coming over here quite quickly
icky and then look at seven o'clock and
Queenie frog here okay Queen takes h3 is
the best move okay there so there were
some opportunities but I couldn't really
figure it out okay yeah I mean this is
the kind of exchange sac that that feels
good from a practical point of view I
hope I didn't didn't spoil it completely
yeah here I was home that I had the
Queen trade high five should this should
end it i took ages to see the mate but
then saw it at the end ok guys thanks
for watching